Hello, I'm John Mullins.
I was born in this house on 4th Street
just off Barrack Street in Cork city.
My parents had four children
and we were on a council waiting list when they moved to nocnahini
on the north side of Cork.
I was educated at the North Monastery
and was student of the year in 1985.
I played Harding and football with the school.
I completed my engineering degree in 1989.
Most graduate of the year in UCC.
In that year I also completed two master's degrees.
I was national present of Young Finigale in the early 90s
when working with ESP. I am married with two adult children.
I have a history of delivery.
I have delivered major assets across four continents
and I am a seasoned international negotiator.
I've dealt with politics all over Europe through my role in Amarranco,
which I founded.
I was appointed chief executive of borgosz at 39 years of age
and I was eight years as chairman of Portugal.
Some examples of these major assets are White Cape power plants,
gas pipelines to County Tiberian,
County Wexford, the new Ring Eskitty Port,
the Sheen Wind Farm and the Enoscara Solar Farm here in court.
I've also had major roles in civic
society and charities on this island.
Cobb Chamber of Commerce, Adam Kara Energy,
Cloud and Cooperation Ireland.
I'm a very active GA member
and I am a director of Supervalu Hockey Keep.
This is an Amarinco Solar found just A site of Cork city
which supplies green energy to 2,000 homes.
This is an example of an asset
that I have delivered in my business career.
And I want to deliver for you in the European Parliament.
I want to create a contract that actually is for farmers
and for non farmers in Roland.
I wanna make sure you're able to bank with any bank across Europe
so you got good value and good service.
I want to use my international negotiation experience
to actually supply you with a better service in Europe.
I want to make sure that migration is fair but firm.
I also want to create Ireland's biggest new industry,
the renewable energy sector.
So deliver for me on June 7th and I will deliver for you in Europe.